up to 30 times faster did blackmagic
design just fix the m1 ultra well today
we will find out because we re-ran a ton
of our tests and new ones to show you
guys how much faster this is and with
that we are going to be answering some
very important questions you guys asked
in monday's video our ultimate video
editing comparison that is jam-packed of
real-world results as well as talk about
some bottlenecks with m1 ultra and when
we can expect updates and fixes from an
insider that was talking to us so let's
go ahead and jump right in now first off
i want to say that video was a crazy
video to make you guys don't know how
much time and effort went into that all
those graphs with the crazy charts
testing retesting it was insane so if
you guys haven't seen that yet and you
care about video editing please check it
out it is still very very relevant and
right after we posted after so much work
days of work black magic design released
davinci resolve 18
which was a bummer and so many of you
guys wanted us to test it because of
that 30 times faster optimized for m1
ultra well let's jump into the results
here i'm going to start out with some of
the bad news and then we'll get into the
good news well for denoising 4k black
magic raw previously we saw 20 frames
per second playback this is very tough
denoising here and with the new update
we are still right there 19 to 20 frames
per second just like before now this
test shows us the raw graphics
performance it is not limited by
anything else so the raw graphics
performance of the 64 core m1 ultra is
still the same and here's the scores
from the other mac studios and using
that raw graphics performance to
stabilize a one minute 4k clip well we
are now actually one second slower now
how about the encoders apple advertised
quad encoders on them and ultra meaning
it should export twice as fast as the m1
max models and we have not seen that yet
well
unfortunately our export times are
identical both for h.264 and h.265 where
actually it got a few seconds slower and
then during playback for smoothness both
of these versions can handle this
without an issue but in fact with
davinci resolve 18 it actually uses more
graphics performance to play this back
which was interesting now the biggest
media engine limitation we saw was with
canon r5 footage this is very difficult
and with all these programs expert times
were identical that's because we're
limited by the decoders and
unfortunately nothing has changed 4k raw
is three seconds slower now and pro res
is two seconds slower what a bummer now
let's jump into some areas that we did
see improvements in for example ak raw
this was the toughest torture test that
is actually about 25 seconds faster not
a huge difference but we actually did
see an improvement playback was still
the same and then 8k redraw there it's
actually five seconds slower now these
are areas with these tougher codecs
where we are not limited by any encoders
it's just pure graphics performance
these are areas that we did not see good
scaling compared to the 48 core and not
amazing compared to the 24 core max
studio that i suggested to a lot of
people so as far as graphics and that
performance of the m1 ultra and
especially the higher end one
we are not seeing great improvements now
i wanted to take a step further because
on their website we see these claims of
30 times faster playback and then so i
went ahead and i did some searches for
mac so we can see exactly what they said
and here we have for the m1 mac models
30 times playback but that's considering
the neural engine and then as far as m1
ultra i did a search and we have that
mentioned four times first time it's
just saying that it's really fast and
powerful that's great second time is
talking about dolby vision and then the
updates there that is awesome and here's
where we have that 30 times faster for
m1 ultra but with more details so if we
take a closer look it says that we have
support for them on ultra it means
faster playback than before a 30 times
faster playback on multicam 8k timelines
okay
that's great what kind of format what
kind of timelines what are the settings
at i did some testing i didn't see any
improvements so i don't know if they
just chose a codec that completely
didn't work and is playing back at one
frames per second because it was
stalling out for multicam that was fixed
and now it's playing back at 30 frames
per second like it should that is a 30
times improvement but unfortunately they
don't give us any info just that tagline
that people are quoting everywhere
commenting because it just sounds so
amazing now they also talk about a
couple of really cool things and
improvements as far as the neural engine
now i wanted to go ahead and test it out
what if now they've unlocked the better
dual neural engines for the m1 ultra
that would be awesome so i ran some of
their ai tools that used the neural
engine and the graphics the first one
was super scale that i took a 1080p
project and then i super scaled it which
uses the neural engine and ai algorithms
to 4k reduces noise and compression
artifacts and i basically saw a small
improvement as far as rendering out that
footage so that it's actually playable
not a big difference at all so that was
a bit disappointing so then i went ahead
and i used their smart reframe for
social media which is an amazing tool
worked super great so i took that six
minute project and i automatically
reframed it for a vertical video and
here it took 33 seconds instead of 35
so yes it has gotten faster but not much
at all not nothing that's going to
change your life nothing that fixes the
m1 ultra and nothing that people are so
hyped about with those kind of 30 times
faster claims that don't have any kind
of backing now if you guys have more
info about what specifically was fixed
let me know down below but this is just
where companies go out and they want to
market their products and make it sound
amazing and it works and you know just
like apple where they release the
previous macbooks and a lot of times
they're saying three times faster but
they're actually comparing to you know
older intel machines that are really
outdated and here at mac set we gotta
show you guys real world results uh for
what we're getting now i do wanna say
that davinci resolve is already the most
optimized if you guys didn't catch it in
my video editing comparison
their program is actually better
optimized for apple silicon the 17
version than final cut pro final cut
throttles the gpu in our torture test
and the 48 core ran at like 900
megahertz where this one will actually
run at the full
1297 or so and then the
64 core instead of running at about 700
ours runs at about 11 27 so that means
that the data is coming in
much better to the gpu to get processed
that is just crazy to see that a
third-party company is doing better than
apple themselves for their hardware so
good job davinci resolve you guys were
already doing a killer job now i want to
answer some questions and then also give
you guys some insider info first let's
go over a couple of these comments right
here jennifer said that we saved her
almost 2 000 euros because she changed
her configuration knowing that she would
have no extra benefits for that higher
end one and i just say that is awesome
this is what we love to do we love to
save you guys money and help you guys
make informed decisions pete mentioned
that it's normal for higher end graphics
to not scale properly and i would say
yes that's true the higher end it gets
you don't get perfect scaling but we
also shouldn't be getting the same
performance as a gpu that has you know
48 cores instead of 64 because this new
one is down clocking its frequency that
is just because of unoptimizations
and just the gpu not working properly so
this is not really the same thing now
mario says that these machines will not
be optimized for years to come there's
going to be a lot of time that's going
to be spent to make this happen and i
think that yes we have to wait for that
but the same time if you are going to be
waiting two years say for optimizations
to come why not just buy the one that
already is working well like the you
know m1 max models that we showed off
how well they work in our previous video
and with that the maxodus he's saying
that what if they're doing this to
constrain the cpu or gpu for the m2
versions no i talked about that in my
previous don't buy video where they
might not be doing it intentionally but
they definitely aren't unlocking any
more performance than what you can get
in their laptops with the m1 max models
even though we have a lot of cooling we
don't have batteries they could be
raising the frequency to get better
performance like a lot of companies do
but they are not and that does help the
m2 stand out more when they come out
they're better optimized the hardware is
better the frequencies are higher
they'll give a much bigger jump in
performance now about our insider leak
or info
basically what we are hearing is that we
will get some good optimizations it
won't be double
but there will be more improvements but
it's going to happen on a software level
for some specific tasks where apple's
going to change up some things but that
is not going to happen until the next
version of mac os and last year it was
shown off at wwdc that's going to be in
june
but it did not come out until october
when new max came out so for those of
you guys that want to have better
encoding speeds with these quad encoders
that's probably going to be the soonest
that we are going to be able to access
that just the way apple does it and the
way their
video engine toolbox works so there you
guys go for all of you guys that were
commenting saying hey you guys missed
the boat davinci resolve 18 is so much
faster those you guys that asked us to
test it this is what we found and
unfortunately no the m1 ultra is still
not that great of a deal for most people
especially not the 64 core model and for
most people unless you know you need the
extra cpu or just the raw graphics power
we would suggest the m1 max models thank
you guys for watching check out our
ultimate video adding comparison there's
so much testing there's so much detail
with premiere pro and resolve and final
cut you guys definitely want to see it
i'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]